well revelers we're ringing in the new
year hundreds of new laws were taking
effect across the country at midnight
the minimum wage increased in 22 States
and in California all illegal immigrants
became eligible for health insurance
under the state's program for low income
residents Jeff Paul joins us live from
Los Angeles with a look at this new
law yeah mly Will starting today
California now becomes the first state
to provide health insurance to all
undocumented people of all ages the
state is now preparing to provide full
coverage to roughly 700,000 individuals
under the state's medical system now
prior to today health insurance was
available to undocumented residents
under the age of 26 but this new law now
expands Healthcare to any age it's
expected to cost the state $3.1 billion
each year California governor Gavin nuum
has called to move a transformative step
towards strengthening the Health Care
system for all Californians however we
should mention as this program begins it
comes as California faces a record 68
billion dollar budget deficit now
another law taking effect today banning
guns in most public places a federal
appeals court on Saturday put a hold on
a previous 9th Circuit Court of Appeals
ruling that the law violated a person's
right to bear arms so for now concealed
carry permit holders won't be able to
bring guns to places like schools
government buildings and on public
transit the California lawmaker who
authored the Bill calls the new law
Common
Sense do you need a gun to go to your
daughter's AYSO soccer game I would say
you need a water bottle and orange
slices right if you go to Dodger Stadium
I would say bring a mitt so your kid can
protect themselves from an errant ball
not from an errant
bullet now around the country 22 states
are all increasing their minimum wage
starting today today the highest minimum
wage will be now in Washington State at
$16.28 the biggest increase will occur
in Hawaii will go from $12 an hour to
$14 an hour Washington DC is also
raising the minimum wage to
$175 and Nevada and Oregon and Florida
are all planning for increases later in
the year Molly a new year could mean
some new things for a lot of people
thank you so much Jeff Paul appreciate
it I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian kilme and
I'm Angley airart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis